hey what's going on everybody
it is may 24th 2021 i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report direct message
and it's monday and i'm feeling
refreshed i had a good weekend
i did literally
literally people not figuratively i did
literally nothing yesterday
i laid on the couch all day long
watched tv ate pasta we had an illegal
party the night before
i don't wanna out myself but we had
about 20 people here
on saturday there was a lot of tequila
flowing
and we catered in david usually likes to
cook but we had about 20 people it's
hard to cook for 20 people
and we just had like trays of pasta left
over and all i did yesterday was lay on
a couch
and eat pasta so i'm filled with carbs
right now and i'm ready to bring you
some information i thought we'd do
something a little bit different today
because you know
obviously the news has been pretty
horrific all around and you know i'm
trying to
dose out the red pills with a little bit
of the clown pills and
keep you guys sane and happy and you
know not crazed but also
somewhat informed uh but you may
remember you know a couple weeks back
maybe over maybe two months ago already
at this point uh we had done
a bunch of episodes where i was laying
in old clips that i had found
of different speeches we played a few of
them from ronald reagan in particularly
and i thought that doing some of those
sort of throwback things just to give a
little context to where we're at in the
world is good so we are going to be
doing one of those
from thomas soul today from about 30
years ago we're gonna do that at the end
of the show which and it's just
sort of like a perfect succinct synopsis
of what's happening right now and that's
the beauty of timeless things if you say
things that are true
they're true 30 years ago and they're
still true now so we're gonna do that
and then just two stories today there's
a whole bunch to get you caught up on
on the covid situation and suddenly
we're allowed to talk about the fact
that maybe it came from a lab
in wuhan i thought that was racist and
it made you a bad
person or a white supremacist or a even
worse a trump supporter
but suddenly everyone's kind of talking
about it so we're going to talk about
that
and then if you didn't see this there
was a two videos
that went viral a couple days ago on
twitter a
u.s army video that's all about
intersectionality and lesbian mothers
and be yourself
and all that stuff uh and someone
spliced it together
with an arm army video from the russian
army
and i think you're gonna see one country
that is ridiculous and one country that
takes itself seriously and the
fundamental difference
between the two so that's all we're
doing today i'm feeling good it's monday
it's hot out here in l.a i'm gonna get
out there with the dog and
not put a mask on and we'll see what
happens but first let's talk about some
of the copied stuff
so the big thing over the last couple
days is that rand paul
who is the libertarian senator
from kentucky who i've had on the show a
couple times you know when people say to
me dave you're always
ragging on all these politicians i have
a short list of politicians
that i think are pretty decent people
doing a pretty decent job and i've put
rand paul
you know pretty much at the top of that
list he doesn't want to control your
life or the life of those
that he governs over and he does not
want to take the covid19 vaccination and
it is my belief that he as a
private citizen in a somewhat free
country is allowed to make that decision
he also
had kovid and he is a doctor so let me
read you the
exact quote he says until they show me
evidence that
people who have already had the
infection are dying in large numbers
or being hospitalized or being very sick
i just made my own personal decision
that i'm not getting vaccinated because
i've already had the disease
and i have natural immunity paul said in
the interview that aired sunday
in a free country you would think that
people would honor the idea that each
individual would get to make the medical
decision
that it wouldn't be a big brother coming
to tell me what i have to do
yes that is quite right we know that if
you've had covid you get antibodies this
is also what herd immunity is about that
if enough people
who are young and relatively healthy get
it and survive it
then not everyone has to get vaccinated
let's also
not forget at one point well before we
were all talking about vaccines we were
talking about two weeks to flatten the
curve
now it's like oh if you're going to go
into mcdonald's you have to be
vaccinated
so i think rand paul making a decision
for himself
and thus uh i assume also a decision for
his family and his children i don't know
what his wife's doing i'm not sure if
she caught cobit or whatever it might be
but he believes that he has the
antibodies in his system and it's
and it's a risk worth taking for him but
he also is a man of science as a doctor
and he's not saying he will never take
it what he's saying there and i think
this is the key part because everyone's
saying
you know i mean on twitter again stay
off twitter if
i if i do nothing else in this world i
hope
that i will have something to do with
the ultimate implosion of twitter which
i do think is going to happen and we all
spend too much time on there myself
included although i don't
do it on the weekends um but anyway
when when uh rand paul said this you
know next thing you know the barrage of
hate on twitter he wants to come and
kill grandma he's anti-science he's an
anti-vaxxer all of that stuff
in essence what he's saying here is hey
if we see
that people who don't take the vaccine
who got the infection in the first place
who had the virus in the first place
if we see a whole bunch of them dying or
show me some other evidence then i will
take it
so he's doing what i think a politician
but not just a politician
he's doing what i would say a a
thoughtful
member of a society would do which is
you balance your personal
right to privacy and liberty and freedom
and decision-making and mental capacity
with that of what the government wants
you to do and what your community wants
you to do and your family and all of
those things so i completely stand
behind rand paul on this and i'm sure
that makes me a white supremacist
somehow
uh the cdc is still recommending that
everyone get the vaccine regardless
of or whether they've had the virus
already so this is their counter sort of
to what rand paul's saying and it's a
very
quick line here experts do not yet know
how long you are protected from getting
sick
after recovering so in essence you get
these antibodies after you get sick
and experts don't know how long they
last now that's that's just fine and i
suppose as time goes on we will find out
more about that and again rand paul is
just making the decision for himself
the cdc is basically saying we don't
know how long that's going to last but
it also seems to me and someone please
correct me
if i'm wrong and i know this is the
internet and i know someone will but
we're already hearing how people are
going to say that
people are saying that you're going to
need booster shots so if you get some of
these vaccines in six months or in nine
months or in a year or even yearly
you're going to have to get these
booster shots so it seems unclear to me
at least that people don't really know
how long the vaccine
in and of itself works there's several
versions of the vaccine obviously
so that also would tell you that whether
you got sick or got the vaccine that
there may be some follow-up stuff
more interestingly i think than all of
that is that suddenly
just in the last like two days suddenly
the internet
is bubbling up with something and this
is one of the good things about the
internet you know i can complain about
internet culture and
mean people and bots and russian trolls
and all the those people
uh and twitter and all that stuff but
one of the things as long as we have a
somewhat free internet that can happen
is you get these sort of fringe voices
that for some time can talk about things
and next thing you know
the media ignores it for a year and then
suddenly it starts kind of being true
and one of those things is there's been
a whole bunch of people in the last year
that are saying that they believe that
the
virus kovid19 came from a lab in wuhan
china trump even hinted at this about a
year ago and everyone said he's evil and
he's a racist and everything else
well now we've got a quote from the
washington post three researchers from
china's wuhan institute of virology
became
sick enough in november 2019 that they
sought hospital care according to a
previously undisclosed
u.s intelligence report that could add
weight to growing calls for a fuller
probe
of whether the covet 19 virus may have
escaped
from the laboratory or the laboratory if
you're british
what i think is interesting about that
they're not saying it absolutely escaped
a laboratory but they're now suddenly
washington post is suddenly saying
maybe it is there have been a bunch of
people uh that have been talking about
this for quite some time on twitter jack
basobia has been talking about it
brett weinstein's been talking about it
that it certainly is a possibility and
whenever
anyone said it they were immediately
told that they're conspiracy theorists
they're like alex jones
blah blah blah and it's like the media
gets everything wrong i mean you guys
know this
the media has just i can't even think of
a story that the media has honestly
covered
what story could well like what sort of
big story over the last
say four years has the media really
gotten right and treated fairly
through a non-political lens so now it's
like well
for the last year and a half you've been
telling us it didn't happen now it's
kind of looking like it did and
my guess if i if i was a betting man you
know
my guess is we're probably gonna find
out more about this and that it probably
did leak from a lab
i i don't know i don't have more
information than you do but the fact
that we're suddenly talking about this
is interesting
and even more interesting and now we've
got video of the infallible fouchy
well he's even kind of saying that maybe
something is up and this is
anthony fauci so in a very minor
collaboration
as part of a subcontract of a grant we
had a collaboration with some chinese
con
chinese uh scientist and and what
he conflated that is that therefore we
were involved in
creating the virus which is the most
ridiculous majestic leap i've ever heard
of
but no i'm not convinced about that i
think that we should continue to
investigate
what went on in china until we find out
to the best of our ability
exactly what happened certainly the
people who've investigated say
it likely was the emergence from an
animal reservoir
that then infected individuals but it
could have been something else
and we need to find that out so you know
that's the reason why i said i'm
perfectly
in favor of any investigation that looks
into the origin
of the virus all right so to be clear
he's not saying
that the virus came from the lab but
he's now saying
maybe and we could kind of look into it
a little bit more the best part of that
whole thing was right at the beginning
did you catch that he almost had a
spectacular freudian slip
he said we had a collaboration with
chinese calm uh
chinese scientists he almost said we had
a collaboration with chinese communists
like he actually almost
said the truth but as far as fouchy i
mean the guy who's just gotten
everything wrong the entire time and
doesn't
live by his own rules and all the rest
of it um the fact that he's even come
this far now
it tells you that something is shaking
like it feels like
the ground is shaking on the narrative
on this one and if we've learned nothing
else over the last couple years usually
the official narrative
is completely wrong so i think we're
gonna find out more on that one quick
other thing on
on the covid stuff is uh gretchen
whitmer who is the
absolutely horrifically awful governor
of
michigan who has been found to break her
own laws a couple times
yeah she broke one of her own luck not
laws they're not laws and i should be
very clear about that because they're
usually edicts
or rules or something that really has no
legal standing well she once again went
to a restaurant and got busted oh
and lori lightfoot remember her the
mayor of chicago who will only be
interested by black uh
interviewed by black or brown people
because she's a racist uh we played a
video last week where she was talking
about how even though she's vaccinated
she's still gonna wear masks
and then literally a few hours after
that very video
she was seen in a whole group uh and
someone had a camera from a far distance
and of course she wasn't wearing a mask
so these people are all hypocrites
ridiculous fools you shouldn't pay any
attention to them you should go about
and live your life and i will say one
other thing which is
that on saturday during the day because
we're having this illegal party at night
uh we were out and about and i have to
say
i was seeing a few more people even here
in bananas los angeles
starting to take off their masks not as
many as i would like
but it's even happening here in the most
blue-pilled
brainwashed lefty democratic dystopia
it's even happening here so something
good
is happening and speaking of something
good i'm now going to show you
a ad from the russian army and
this video went viral as i said because
somebody looped it together
with an ad from the american army and
it's an incredible
just a truly incredible juxtaposition
of the way one country behaves in a
serious manner and
in the way another country behaves
unfortunately the united states in a
completely
unserious manner this was retweeted by
all all sorts of people including ted
cruz and then of course he started
getting called a russian asset and
everything else so first let's show you
this russian
army video
games
[Music]
foreign
all right i don't speak russia but
russian but i assume he was saying
something to the effect of you know
we're
serious people and i've got to go do
something and i'm fighting for my
country and
that's what we're going to go do i also
think dan was it dan schneider zack
snyder
zack snyder of justice league probably
directed that thing you can see you
don't even need to know exactly what
he's saying to understand
and whether you think it's propaganda or
not we can have all of those debates
but what you're seeing is the russian
government is putting out an ad saying
we want soldiers we want to be able to
defend our country
we're going to do what we got to do now
allow me to show you what the u.s army
put out last week
it begins in california with a little
girl
raised by two moms i also marched for
equality
i like to think i've been defending
freedom from an early age
standing at the altar to marry my other
mom
with such powerful role models i
finished high school at the top of my
class
i found it a way to prove my inner
strength
and maybe shatter some stereotypes along
the way
i'm us army corporal emma malone lord
and i answered my calling
we're screwed people you get it you get
it like can you imagine
that russian guy coming up against that
girl no offense to that girl
no offense to her lesbian mothers no
offense to the marching
no offense to equality no offense to any
of that
but if you give me a you know east
village lesbian
vs vladimir putin who's going to win
what are we doing what are we doing
that's great
nobody cares if you're gay nobody cares
if you're straight nobody cares if
you're trans
but which one of those seems like a
country that is that is saying we
we are here we are here for a purpose we
are here to defend ourselves we are here
because we believe
in the the documents that got us here
and we are
strong and don't mess with us at all of
that stuff
now again maybe the russian one is
propaganda
i'm not going to sit here i'm not going
to sit here and defend a russian army ad
right although i would defend ivan drago
fighting
rocky balboa in moscow on christmas
day in 1985 i believe that was um
but it's just like you see these two
things do we have a problem here like
we got a real problem here and we're
gonna have to figure out how to deal
with that
by the way this is fantastic conor
showed me this my director showed me
this right before
uh we started on that youtube video on
the us army ad now they shut off
comments so you're not allowed to
comment on that but this is
absolutely incredible there are four
point
two thousand so 4 200 likes
4.2 000 likes 86
000 dislikes is this are we inspiring
people
are we inspiring people i don't know you
know you can only garner or glean that
much
information from likes on youtube videos
but like something ain't right and again
i just want to
say fantastic work with that cartoon
girl and her lesbian mothers nobody's
that's wonderful it's great not that
there's anything wrong with that
it's just wonderful but i think putin's
got a leg up on us like putin's watching
that video going
we're okay guys don't worry invasion
begin next week
okay all right so i want to do one more
thing so i didn't feel like doing just
all
current events uh this week because it
was obviously last week with the with
the just
attacks on random jews throughout the
united states it was just
and again having nothing to do it
doesn't matter what you think of israel
it doesn't matter what you think of the
palestinians it doesn't matter what you
think of the middle east
all of those things we can't have just
violent sectarian violence on our
streets meaning
doesn't matter what's going on across
the world we can't have our citizens
attacking
our own citizens and unfortunately
this is really what aoc and and talib
and omar and the hamas wing
of the democratic party this is what
they've brought on biden gave like a
really wishy-washy statement on it i
think yesterday
and and bernie sanders who's just the
worst of the worst and by the way bernie
sanders big brooklyn jew
and they're coming for you one day
bernie uh you're just you're just a tool
in the revolution which is the
nice part of this thing like they'll
take out bernie as i've been saying for
years
but bernie tweeted out something about
uh we must stop the rise in
anti-semitism and islamophobia
and it's like what are you talking about
like he can't even
they're literally just hunting down jews
in new york city going to the diamond
district where they know jews work
throwing you know explosives beating
people on the street
and bernie can't even give a
full-throated condemnation of that
because that's how twisted uh this this
marxist woke ideology is
if if you see a group that doesn't count
your intersectional calculator in this
case jews also asians
well then you got to figure out a way to
make it work so oh we condemn the
anti-jews stuff and the islamophobia but
what are you talking about
what what what are you talking about
anyway moving on from all of that
although it's loosely loosely connected
i think you'll see why in just a sec
we found this old clip of thomas soul
and i've been quoting thomas soul so
often lately
and i think you guys know i just
finished my second book and i go into a
little bit more about what it was like
to interview him and and how he affected
me and everything else
so we've been finding these videos on
youtube and i thought it would be
interesting to play this and analyze it
a little bit after this is from
uh free to choose enterprise uh an inter
this was actually a debate that thomas
all did and this is probably about 30
years ago or so
you keep telling me how these are
wonderful ideas it's just that they
never work out in practice
it's like the marxists who are telling
us that eastern europe wasn't really
socialism nothing that ever existed on
this earth
was ever really socialism it's only
in their imagination at some points you
have to ask yourself could it be that
this principle
cannot work out in practice with human
beings as they exist on this planet
ah i just love that i know it's just a
quick little bite there
we didn't want to overload you uh you
know why don't we link to the to the
full thing down below we'll link to the
full thing if you want to watch
actually the whole the whole
conversation there but that last line
there at some point you have to ask
yourself
could it be that this principle cannot
work out in practice
with human beings as they exist on this
planet and that's exactly
as i often talk about the thanos
principle
of the left which is they believe they
can create this perfect system the
perfect system
never works anywhere and always kills a
lot of people communism
and and socialism have killed millions
and millions of people
caused massive migration across the
world
to come to places like america to escape
that [ __ ] and now these buffoons are
importing it
and i call this the thanos principle
because what did thanos want there are
finite resources and i'll do the thing
that nobody else will do i will snap my
fingers and wipe out half of existence
because i'm the good guy thus
there will be peace it's very it's very
emperor palpatine too
um but i love this because it's such a
perfect example of what
of what soul actually is
the work that he's done for decades and
and who he is as a human being
which is if you read any of his books
and i've read several of them if you
read any of his books the guy
loves facts and information and you guys
know there was that viral clip of when i
interviewed him and i said
you know you were a communist you were a
socialist what woke you up
to what was wrong with that line of
thinking and he goes uh
facts and it's just so perfect because
so many people i think right now want to
make the world whatever they want it to
be
and i think someone like thomas sol he
sees the world as it is
and not as he wishes it to be i think
i'd
probably in some ways see it very
similarly like the world is what it is i
might want to be able to change some of
the stuff on the margins
but so many people think that they can
just burn through everything before them
and completely change it
um so his point there was oh this is
what i mean and you see this all the
time even from the official
socialist accounts the blue check
verified socialist accounts on twitter
uh which is ironic in and of itself but
they'll always tell you well socialism
hasn't been
done properly venezuela wasn't really
socialist
or communism wasn't done properly with
with in russia
and like all of these things and it's
like well maybe it just doesn't work
because you know who's the problem in
the system it's us it's human beings
it's the individual that really
is the truth and right now what we're
seeing all over the world
is big systems big government big
um these these organizations these
worldwide organizations like the who and
the cdc and all these things
they keep giving us rules and edicts and
the government
wants to come in and tell us how much to
pay our employees and what we can wear
when we walk outside and when
when we can inject ourselves with
something and when we can inject
ourselves a second time and all of these
things
and the problem in the system is that
humans have choice and as long as humans
have choice and i'm sure they're working
somewhere in a laboratory on getting rid
of
human choice i thought she's probably
funding the thing
but as long as humans have choice we are
the problem in big systems so i will
continue to fight with you good people
because uh what else am i gonna do
i don't have anything better to do than
save the world do you let's keep going
guys part one of my interview with
steven crowder we did a mini
interview because his channel now
has two strikes and the way that it
works on youtube if you get three
strikes
i'll thanos it you are gone okay
deleted forever he now has two strikes
on his channel
he is suing youtube we get into the
details of why he's doing it and why he
believes he has a good case
but youtube could just take him out
tomorrow we know that there's so much
arbitrary nonsense by the way i keep
getting tons and tons of messages
from you guys that you're not seeing our
videos in your feed
you know thank you youtube overlords but
please make sure that you're subscribed
as i always tell you in that
notification bell i'm not sure if it
even works
but you may as well at least try it uh
so we go into that with uh
with crowder and i mean the idea that a
guy like crowder could be booted
you know it's one of those things they
weren't gonna stop with alex jones
they're always gonna move move move and
it's like all right you take out crowder
well how close are you to ruben how
close are you to shapiro or peterson or
anyone else
and and maybe that really is what the
move here is making if only someone had
started a tech company where creators
could own all of their stuff yeah
uh who who was that guy who was me
locals.com guys
uh oh and i'm very excited about this
one i did this on friday i interviewed
mark mccloskey mark mccloskey who of
course
was the man in missouri during the riots
of the summer
who the black lives matter antifa mob
broke into his private street broke the
gate down
and he walked outside with his wife with
the gun remember he's holding
the big gun his wife's got the little
pistol there's that sort of iconic
picture of the two of them defending
their
property which is their god-given right
in america well he is now
running for senator in missouri it's an
awesome story i mean a guy almost gets
demolished by the mob literally and
figuratively
right the mob almost came to his house
and burned it down and then the media
starts calling him a white supremacist
and a trump supporter and
all the evil the evil evil things that
one can be
well he has survived the mob and he
decided to get
in the game so i interviewed him he's
ready to fight
he's ready to fight and i would say this
you know i said last week
that i think the caitlyn jenner thing is
just complete bs they still have not
responded to us why don't we follow up
again actually
uh and it's like you don't have to do
the show but if you can't even respond
then you're just not serious one way or
another
uh so we will we will follow up with
them that's not a serious thing
this guy's serious he's running and he
wants to fix this country
and uh and it's just a great interview
and you'll get to see a different side
of him
uh for more if you want to play along or
talk to me directly
reubenreport.locals.com we are testing
live video streaming starting this week
i can't wait to show you guys what we're
going to be doing with that we got a lot
of interesting
things cooking that's all for me going
to the dentist
getting my uh i do it semi-annually i'm
getting my semi-annual teeth cleaning so
that's what i'll be doing for the rest
of the afternoon and uh you know let's
just keep going guys we're
everything's gonna be all right that's
my that's my main message today
everything's gonna be all right all
right see you tomorrow